Welcome back everyoneit's Charlie this is my
full House Of The Dragon Episode 9 video
there were a whole bunch of Easter
eggs and references so we'll break it all down if
you're brand new to the channel I'm doing videos
for all the episodes be sure to subscribe to get
them and careful for spoilers from the episode
if you haven't seen it yet we'll start at the
beginning and work our way through shop by shot
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments but the
dance of the Dragons has finally begun like the
opening Salvo has been fought the actual episode
title is the green council it's a reference to the
new small council that Otto Hightower creates
after they usurp the crown and name aegon the
second the next king killing or purging everyone
in court in the small council who was loyal to
rhaenyra they changed the intro scene to represent
viserys's symbol filling it with blood denoting
that he's died like anytime a member in the line
of succession dies their symbol fills up with
blood you also may have noticed the sapphire
on one of alicenit's children's symbols here
that's for Aemond because one of his eyes the
one that got cut out is actually been replaced
by a sapphire I think we'll actually see it
in episode 10 because it seems like he takes
his eye patch off in the trailer there's also new
sections to represent the children that aegon has
had with Helaena we see them during the episode
and also the new children that rhaenyra has had
with Daemon we actually found out about another
missing child that they're going to feature during
season two that also might happen with some of the
other children because like for instance aegon and
Helena have a third child but we haven't seen it
yet so it might just not have been born yet so
as many kids as you think there are now there'll
be more kids coming in season two but the actual
opening starts in the moments after viserys's
death in the wee hours of the morning in the empty
iron throat I love the way that they start on the
empty Iron Throne just represent what's about to
happen and it's pretty much the same deal around
the rest of the red keep like it's totally quiet
totally empty until one of the random servant
children finds that viserys has died if it wasn't
clear this young child here isn't one of the
targaryens even though he's wearing red he's just
one of the servant boys they said that the whole
varus storyline going on in the episode between
baseria and Laris strong because both of them
are kind of like mistress and master of Whispers
so to speak in the whole spy network that larys
tells alicent about when he's trying to basically
create the official master of whispers position
on the small council is in telling her about
what's happening here like oh your servant girl
is actually working for the White Worm this area
when the small council convenes right after this
to discuss what they're going to do immediately
after and they joke about a possible war with
Dorne the reason why they're joking about that
is because Dorne still isn't part of the Seven
Kingdoms that doesn't happen until much later in
the timeline you also probably noticed that tyland
lannister's ball is gold because Lannister's gold
reference A Lannister Always Pays his debts sounds
like he's paying his debt with his allegiance to
this green Council but the crazy thing we find
out is that they always had a plan to usurp the
throne kill runira and Daemon and their children
no matter what happened so even though alicent
makes this big deal in the episode about hearing
viserys's last dying wishes they really just use
that to kind of help their cause but they had
always planned to use serp the throne it didn't
matter that viserys actually said that some of
you are wondering about what alicent was going
to do like if she didn't hear viserys talk about
aegon and the prophecy and mistake it for aegon II
would she still have done the same thing that's
always possible but I think that doesn't matter
because the whole idea is that it didn't matter
to her father like he was always going to use serp
the throne the they wind up having a big argument
about that at the end of the episode so we'll see
what's going to happen with aegon the second like
will he turn into another Joffrey because alicent
seems like she's trying to bring her father under
her control will that work will it not work will
she be able to control igon II we'll see just
remember Cersei was not able to control Joffrey it
seems like most people on the small Council will
already Team Green before this but obviously Lord
beesberry is one of the lone dissenters is like
wait a minute we can't do this this is ridiculous
R.I.P Lord beesbury though because Criston Cole
kills him the only thing about his death is
that it seems that Criston Cole is surprised by
actually killing him like he didn't totally plan
on killing him he was just trying to get him to
shut up the way the actor who plays Criston Cole
talks about his character is he says he's a dirt
bag and he just uses all these circumstances to do
whatever he wants to do to like free the Beast so
to speak metaphorically and literally even though
he has all these conversations with aemond about
being an honorable person and not getting up to
all the dirty stuff that aegon does in flea bottom
really the actor is saying the inside he's just as
terrible a person and I think the same is true for
aim it as well even though they don't spend all
their nights in flea bottom they're still really
terrible people you have the whole conflict with
Harold westerling and Criston Cole it definitely
seems like Criston Cole is going to try to kill
him later even though he takes his white cloak off
I don't think he's officially resigning his post
as Lord commander of the King's Guard he just says
he's waiting for the next king whoever that might
be to give him orders but alicent basically says
that Criston Cole is going to be named the next
Lord Commander so I think they're going to try
and get rid of Harold Westerling no matter what
and even though they do try to make the green seem
really shady with what's going down here they at
least want to make alicent seem like she's trying
not to hurt rhaenyra like she doesn't want to kill
her even though she still believes in upholding
the status quo like aegon must be king because
she gets so pissed off when she finds out their
plans to just kill them right off and even later
in the episode she demands of her father that they
not kill them and again to aegon when they're on
their way to the great sept to name him King this
is also another reference to what app with Joffrey
Cersei and Ned Stark so the whole idea is that Ned
Stark died in season one big WTF moment Joffrey
had him be headed but the thing was is that Cersei
didn't want him to do that he went rogue and did
it on his own and it's another example of Cersei
not being able to control him like wait Joffrey
you weren't supposed to do that we were supposed
to offer him clemency that's the whole reason why
he confessed we'll see if aegon winds up falling
down that slippery slope like will he become more
and more terrible your grandfather is going to
tell you to kill your sister and her family but
don't listen to that Council so they're trying
not to completely demonize alicent despite what
the people around her and her son might wind
up doing I think that's because as we get into
future Seasons as the actual Dance of the Dragons
gets really crazy like all the kids start fighting
each other on Dragon back and you start seeing
bodies flying all over the place they don't want
to completely demonize either alicent or rhaenyra
like everyone involved in this conflict is going
to wind up doing very very terrible things on
both sides side Note 2 during this conversation
alicent mentions the wall and it's one of the
only times someone on the show has mentioned the
wall aside from viserys during his dying breasts
in the last episode then we see Helena Targaryen
with her children with aegon she says it is Our
Fate to Crave always what is given to another if
one possesses a thing the other will take it away
and that's obviously a reference to the events of
this episode them taking away rhaenyra's Crown you
also notice that she's embroidering a spider which
is a call back to the spider from the dance of the
Dragons Dragon dream that she had as a girl during
the last big funeral and talarus strong going
full Varys like he is a spider like Varys was the
spider if it wasn't clear her two children with
aegon here are jahiris and Jahira they do have a
third child like I said named mailor we might see
them in season two the other missing child that
you may have heard about is alicent's fourth child
with viserys like they had another child that they
just haven't featured on the show his name is
Daeron George RR Martin said that he is alive and
they'll feature him during season two they just
didn't have time to feature him during this season
when Helena says there is a beast beneath the
boards and gets really upset when alicent starts
talking to her about aegon's whereabouts what
she's talking about is another callback to last
week's episode where she made the same comment in
a more jokey Manner and it's a reference to aegon
using the secret passageways to get out at night
to go to flea bottom and these are the places and
just spend all the time with the women like later
in the episode we find out that he probably has
many bastards running around flea bottom so that's
the reason why she gets so upset when she says
there's a beast beneath the boards but I also
think that it might be foreshadowing for blood
and cheese stuff in future Seasons no spoilers
about what that means but if you know you know
it's all about the secret passageways with people
using them to get out of the red keep and into the
red keep without being seen you also notice that
aemond is the first person to come to Helaena's
Chambers because they have this weird connection
like I don't know how Helaena feels about Aemond
but aymond definitely feels very special about
Helaena I don't know if they have any kind of
crazy Jamie Cersei thing going on on the side
because Aemond later tells Criston Cole about his
plan to eventually become king like it should be
me I'm the one that's studying all this stuff I'm
much better than my brother I ride the biggest
dragon in the Kingdom Loki I think the Aemond
wants to get rid of his brother somehow and marry
his sister Helaena Targaryen they also kind of
imply there's this weird sexual connection between
Criston Cole and alicent like whatever you feel
for me I'm your queen later might be some weird
romantic thing that developed between the two
of them because there's a whole weird Kink going
on with lyrics strong and alicent that we learned
about later don't worry I will address that in a
second the reason why multiple different groups of
people are sent to find aegon is because they're
really worried about what's going to happen to him
because of how fast they're trying to move and
because they don't want aegon getting away they
imply the twin brothers are going to take aegon
somewhere where he won't have to become king like
they're going to help him get away alicent wants
to prevent that that's why she's asking Criston
Cole to make sure that that doesn't happen
like make sure he comes back to me also it's
more about her taking power back from her father
like her father seems like he's been pushing it
around this chessboard playing the game of thrones
with her this whole time she even references that
during the episode so she's trying to realign
power around herself so to speak love Aemond's
story about back during his 13th birthday party
it's time to get it wet aegon trying to be the
good brother helping his other brother get laid
the woman remembers him ah my have you grown when
she says the aegon's tastes are less discerning
than they used to be that's just a reference to
all the fighting pits that he goes to like this
really crazy stuff that messerio is trying to
get rid of that's part of the bargain that mysaria
makes with Otto Hightower remember your grandson
is becoming King only because of me all the
children that are fighting in those pits are just
from women that had Random Encounters that work
at the pleasure houses so there's just a bunch
of Orphan kids that nobody cares about except for
people like Miss area we see one of aegon's many
bastards we'll see what happens to them in the
future because if you remember in season two I
think with season two episode one Joffrey had the
goal closed around and kill all Robert's bastards
without being able to find Gendry Otto Hightower
has all of renira's supporters amongst Lords and
Ladies of the realm like the more powerful people
the more powerful houses either bend the knee or
get kicked out most of them aren't killed except
for Lord Caswell he tries to escape but then is
caught and hung inside the red keep the silent
sisters prepare viserys's body remember they're
going to burn him because it's part of the
Targaryen Customs one of the Dragons will
incinerate his body obviously it's also meant to
be a parallel to him doing the same thing to his
wife Emma burning her per their Customs we get
this really great scene with with rhaenys and
alicent with her trying to convince her to come
to Team Green the funny thing here though is that
alicent basically insults the hell out of her and
her house she says all the things that she refused
to say out loud before she even tries to appeal to
the fact that she should have been Queen instead
of her husband viserys like you should have been
the one to sit on the Iron Throne my husband was
just meant to read books and study history and
play with his models but the reason why rhaenys
really gets upset with her is because alicent is
just trying to uphold the status quo saying that
no women shouldn't be on the Iron Throne we're
only meant to advise men and rhaenys is like oh
hell no like she calls alicent a prisoner to the
establishment so to speak like you're creating a
window in that prison of yours that you're living
in during Otto High Towers meeting with Miss area
there's a little bit of foreshadowing too when
she says there's no power but what the people
allow you to take that's going to be a reference
to Future Seasons because there are a couple
riots that happen during the dance of the dragons
we'll talk about a future season some of them are
a little bit spoilery so we'll wait to talk about
them but it's another callback to Daemon telling
rhaenyra to listen to the will of the commoners
because for the most part the commoners don't
really care who their next king is or who the next
ruler is as long as there's stability in the realm
that's why during the actual coronation later when
they're actually putting the crown on aegon's head
the crowd is just kind of like oh okay I guess
this is okay let the people cheer a little bit
but it's not like everybody is going crazy at the
thought of him becoming king love the scene and
then trying to drag aegon out of the great sept
he does not want it he's going full Jon Snow don't
make me take the iron throne but Criston Cole and
Aemond show up to grab aegon from them they only
get Arryk with an a Erryk with an e is the one
that gets away to go back in free rhaenys also
love the scene where aegon makes this impassioned
speech to Aemond that they both just take off on a
ship and never come back no one will ever find
us let's just run away which is meant to be a
parallel for Criston Cole telling the same thing
to rhaenyra when they were younger let's just get
out of here we'll run to the east nobody will know
who we are we can do whatever we want then we get
that crazy crazy scene with Lair strong telling
alicent all about mysterious little birds her spy
Network so to speak to convince her to to set him
up is the official master of Whispers on her new
green small Council her green Council Varys was
Master of Whispers to the Mad King and then to
Robert Baratheon and then to Joffrey and so on and
so forth but the position of Master of Whispers
didn't always exist I think they're trying to say
that it started around this period when they show
his Cane there's a B on it that's meant to
represent his role in alicent's life so you
remember the conversation they had in the godswood
where he was looking at the flowers making this
metaphor about how she was like a flower surviving
in this foreign environment inside the red keep
where nobody liked her nobody supported her but
she's flourished since then bees pollinate flower
and help them survive So lyrics has helped her
survive this whole time but the crazy dragon
in the room we have to address it seems like this
whole time part of their Arrangement is that when
he gives her information or helps her out the
payment that he receives from her is that she
basically just feeds his kink by showing him her
bare feet like that's his Kink he even goes for it
right in front of her like she just kind of wait
like okay just finish finish so we can get out of
here somehow that seems crazier than some of the
spicier Game of Thrones scenes that we've seen so
far rhaenys winds up getting out of the red keep
using the secret passageways with the help of the
other twin brother Eric who escaped she's able to
use the crowd to get to the Great sept and use the
confusion to get to the dragon pit and get on her
Dragon melees we'll get to that part in a second
we have to talk about the coronation for a little
while they show you a lot of the items they're
using at the actual coronation they have the
special scroll that the high septon uses at each
of the different coronations that seems like it
goes back to the time of aegon the Conqueror the
important thing about becoming king of Westeros
is that the high septon actually has to perform
the ceremony so even though Westeros used to have
all these Petty Kings these different kingdoms
before the conquest when aegon conquered the Seven
Kingdoms right afterwards he went to Old Town and
had the high septon of the day name him the king
of Westeros it was until after that that he moved
the capital to King's Landing they use aegon the
conquerors Valyrian steel Crown you notice it has
the same red ruby in the middle of it that's
on the Valyrian dagger which they also wind up
giving to egg on the second they also give him
aegon's ancestral Valerian blade blackfyre which
is typically passed from each King to the next
but I love on the way to the coronation like this
is more of aegon not wanting to be king he doesn't
believe his mother about viserys he never loved me
he's only half true about that like viserys didn't
hate his children with alicent he just didn't love
them as much as he loved runyera clearly he also
loved his first wife Emma way more than he loved
alicent but when she shows him the Valerian dagger
for like a hot second you could see on his face
like he wants to believe it like I kind of don't
believe you but I really want to believe you that
my father loved me and when the gold cloaks
Usher him to the dias and they start naming
him king start performing the ceremony it seems
like he actually wants to believe the hype for a
second like he starts to drink the Kool-Aid just a
little I love the way that Helaena is clocking him
during the ceremony too like everyone is kind of
looking out at the crowd but Helaena is staring at
him you have to remember she has dragon dreams all
the time so she's seen aegon's future even though
she doesn't totally understand it probably one of
her early Ddragon dreams was actually about aegon
II's future I don't want to talk too much about
at it here because it's kind of a spoiler but
it'll probably get paid off in maybe season two
maybe season three we'll see like however many
seasons the show winds up running they implied the
show will run Four Seasons so it might be season
four but remember the look on aegon's face when he
pulls out blackfyre and holds it up to the crowd
like he starts to drink the Kool-Aid do you think
that he's gonna find out being a little bit like
Joffrey will alicent be able to control him so
to speak also important side note one of Criston
Cole's nicknames is the king maker mostly because
of his support of aegon II but that's why I think
in the episode he literally places the crown on
aegon II's head just to pay off that reference
then we get the awesome dragon attack by rhaenys
in her really really cool looking Targaryen armor
now it's red for targaryens but also her dragon
melees is referred to as the Red Queen and this
is why her armor looks similar to Daemon's dragon
scale armor when she says she's afraid to leave
melees in the dragon pick like I'm not gonna
leave her behind that's another big deal too
because you remember the dragons are basically
trapped inside the dragon pit so even though
the dragons are like nuclear weapons you'd think
that they'd be super powerful people they become
incredibly vulnerable when they're held inside
the dragon pit so you actually don't want that
technically like the whole concept of the dragon
pit was a bad idea it was actually maegor who
created the dragon pit on top of the last great
sept after a big faith militant Uprising so they
wanted the moment of rhaenys crashing through
the top of this great steps to be really ironic
in that sense like haha we're destroying another
great sept with dragons just like maegor did a
long time ago but unlike maegor she doesn't want
to kill the greens remember way back in episode
1 she referenced maegor saying that had been a
long time since the realm had experienced any
real war so there's just a lot of maegor easter
eggs with rhaenys character but she's not like
megor at all like she's actually a pretty good
person even though there's a lot of collateral
damage happening in here inside the great sept she
spares the family I think because she doesn't want
to be a complete psychopath like she's showing
them mercy and then takes off to Dragonstone
obviously to tell rhaenyra about what's happened
and they can formulate their plans for the coming
War the dance of the Dragons if you spotted any
other Easter eggs and references in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video just write
down below in the comments in my full episode 10
finale trailer video we'll post next everyone
click here for that finale trailer I'll update
the link as soon as I post it and click here
for all my other house of the dragon videos
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!